hello and welcome to this video this is
Pedro Pedro paiva something like that
almost certainly not pronouncing this
correctly it okay so let's play the
night off yeah this is the h3 night off
I think this is an interesting line for
white i'm currently studying this I know
it sounds a bit weird be called Lema I'm
not an e4 player and usually but i'm
working on you form repertoires for
white and this is part of it Queen 85
okay I don't know that will be should be
too threatening stuff night XD 5 first
and foremost it's like I'm gaining a
tempo he probably has to move the Queen
again oh no okay well but this is not
bad right I've got a very good
development and it looks a little bit we
adhere to black
yeah it's probably going all the way
back or there we have it ok I think this
is something that I probably like to do
give him the double points there is 93
to h5 as an idea here yeah probably
first to this and then see I wonder oh
that's an interesting move but I have GF
g 5 right then is going book g8 on hmm I
also can play Nigeria here in this
position
so g5 rook g8 I don't I don't really
have a direct attacking idea and this
and this here can also just play the
Queen and let him basically um let him
take a move like Queen Queen up queen
bee three or something like that one
night g3 may be 93 4 94 is this actually
a good idea and I cannot do to primos
and once there so it will probably take
anyway on it says something else that
makes any sense doesn't look like it
so night h5 a certain idea and generally
I mean I'm better developed and also
maybe half good to f3 here somewhere to
attack f6 even though that's not a very
serious-looking attack the main issue
that he has us he he should castle
somehow or get his King get his King out
of this but it's difficult to do and
turn yeah wow talk about overlooking a
move did not see this at all didn't see
this move it on I don't know how bad
this is that I didn't see it but I
should have I also cannot cancel long at
the moment but ha ha if I tell you that
I didn't see this would you believe me
you're probably would write oh my god I
I did not see this at all Wow ok I mean
ah ok I mean I only have one move here
so it's that because I don't play you
for all that often a little bit maybe
I'm not so used to the two what's going
on here but still yeah I should see this
oh my god so I can check him here
I'm starting with this move if he takes
with the pawn I have 96 and Bishop takes
I have a bit more in terms of
possibilities are saying because f8 it
kind of doesn't have Bishop f8 at some
points let's see i can check in and
Bishop before like checking in seven
Bishop before but you can take be tool
which does work okay yeah hmm i think g6
is probably the most interesting one mm
it's got queen it's got to go into g one
problem i wonder if Queen h5 is a move
here threatening g6 it is maybe a bit
slow yeah anyway wow i blundered a full
look that I didn't see Quincy one at all
and you can probably take a 2 a.m.
I wonder if I could have played
something else though instead of Korea
free maybe I didn't have a really good
move their Queens you one now right 3g
one Queen g1 prevents g6 he probably
should play the smooth I don't know what
I'm doing then 93 looks wrong no maybe
Queens you want to sell something else I
can do I think I go 93 you just trying
to rock the queen of squares
I don't really see anything else to be
honest I wanted to go to g6 like
whatever but maybe maybe I can actually
do this next move i can write back here
first and then g6 cannot prevent g6
Quincy one is an idea for potentially
Queen to h6 like Quincy 1g six Queen h6
it's still not that easy to play for him
I mean I'm lost their objectively but
it's still not an easy thing to play hi
morning at least a cat this is how it
feels to me me having those pieces are
not super activeâ so he should have a
win definitely so how do i still post
problems here be sure before and not yet
he can take with the Queen so I have to
do something like that Mia here I can
take I can take it doesn't really do
much cut the Queen g8 is not threatening
anything yeah anyway everything I would
like to but somehow get the night now
this is getting someone more interesting
now oh it takes the shot in see it hmm
oh oh yeah come on 3g one guy am wow
that I thought I simply missed that I
mean the position i think was pretty
favorable hot white but I completely a
completely missed twin G whoa check okay
so um so the engine likes white a lot
which it's not not a big surprise I mean
hehe I don't really see how he gets out
of the position here yakking you to us
will have to do but ok this is actually
renders 94 somewhat suspect because I
mean I don't I don't need this yeah let
the creek comes to H to the computer
wants to play here intending queen age
seven yeah this is just not a good
position not a good position for black
the sugar for i can switch this on we
should have 492 yeah well okay you don't
need to analyze this it's pretty it's
pretty rotten for black but i'd totally
did not seek reach before I came Wow
yeah I have to go King e2 he moved at
him may I have to do that it's still
good for white but this is not of course
what I would I need them I can I can do
this Queen d3 before and black as pretty
much toast without any anything I just
totally missed the move yeah auntie I'm
just I'm just fishing yeah I don't know
after i was talking Queen g1 or quincy
one should be good but his f5 is this is
also also probably okay yeah 93 you
don't want to go back maybe this is a
little bit of
tougher task for blanket but I couldn't
really i mean i'm a rope down and the
position was good but it is not good
enough for hot compensating along oh
yeah here there's very little that you
can do ha ha yeah brooke is too much the
rookies too much yeah but for those of
you interested in the opening by the way
like h3e 6g 45 I think that t2 t2 is a
very good move against us I only
recently found that I mean not like I
discovered it I found that this is a
move and there was I wasn't aware of
this and I think white is better I know
it looks a little bit strange this
voluntary will eternally retreat but
there is pressure on d5 and I mean queen
egg 5s is definitely wrong they're
usually them playing I think we should
before but I think also their wine is a
bit better but just a bit in the game
black was what's as much worse ok guys
thanks for watching